m
à la pointe occidentale de l'autriche la
région du brigham sur valdes a réussi le
pari d'être une terre de tourisme tout
en préservant son âme rural et ses
traditions en témoigne la route du
fromage au sein de cette association
fromage et restaurateurs commerçants et
artisans partagent leur savoir-faire
avec passion et enthousiasme
partons ensemble à leur rencontre
auteur de guides de randonnées rudolph
berges tel est un véritable amoureux de
la région
le breakdancer valdes appartient au land
du vorarlberg
il compte 22 villages quelques trente
mille habitants et autant de vaches et
s'étend sur 550 kilomètres carrés la
route du fromage traverse la région sur
75 km
notre randonnée gourmande débute dans le
village de chopper now à 900 mètres
d'altitude
autrefois et les habitants y mener une
vie très frugale souvent une soupe aux
grues ont constitué l'essentiel de leurs
repas le souper des pauvres gens comme
on l'appelait alors pour erwin casper
chef étoilé cette soupe fait partie de
l'histoire de la région il tient à
perpétuer cette tradition
halte et
erwin qu'espère mouiller le roux d'eau
et de vin rouge et poivre abondamment
ensuite il fait revenir des croûtons de
pain de singles dans du beurre qui
viendront généreusement agrémenter la
soupe
encore quelques dés de fromage d'alpage
et un peu de ciboulette et la soupe est
prête un plat d'hiver simple mais
savoureux et surtout très nourrissant de
quoi nous donner des forces pour la
suite de notre voyage
prenons un peu de hauteur les
télécabines nous emmène en une vingtaine
de minutes aux didams coop à deux milles
90 mètres d'altitude
là où la vue est un véritable
enchantement
en revanche il faut près de trois heures
et demie de marche pour venir à bout du
sommet
mais quelle récompense une fois arrivé
au but plus de 300 sommet allemands
suisses autrichiens et lichtensteinois
s'offrent à notre regard un panorama
d'une poésie rude
d'une beauté à couper le souffle
d'étranges silhouettes se détache du
paysage immobile elle semble contempler
les montagnes tout auréolé de brume il
s'agit de l'installation aux reason
field du sculpteur anglais anthony
gormley
éparpillés sur plus de 150 kilomètres
carrés sans personnage de plomb sont
placés à exactement
2039 mètres d'altitude à leur côté on ne
peut s'empêcher de trouver l'homme bien
petit face à cette nature grandiose qui
existaient bien avant lui
en été les auteurs sont le domaine des
troupeaux qui prennent leurs quartiers
dans les pâturages d'altitude
accompagnés de leur gardien
yoann fink est l'un d'entre eux toute la
belle saison il s'occupe de l'une des
fermes d'alpage une fois par semaine ses
frères et son père vienne lui apporter
des provisions de la vallée l'occasion
aux deux bavarder un peu et de prendre
des nouvelles du village
ces montagnes ont vu naître l'une des
personnalités les plus importantes de la
région frantz michael ryder né en 1839 à
chaud par nao dans une famille de la
classe moyenne paysanne il est considéré
comme le premier réformateur social du
vorarlberg
le musée qui lui est consacré retrace le
parcours de cet homme qui n'eut de cesse
de vouloir améliorer les conditions
sociales difficiles des habitants pour
rompre le monopole économique des
marchands de fromage felder créa la
première coopérative agricole
dans de nombreux écrits france mickaël
felder développe à sa critique de la
société et ses utopies sociales il est
également l'auteur de nombreux poèmes
bucolique souvent mystique
l'écrivaine birgit ritzler se sent porté
par cet héritage dans les gorges de
l'argonne ou felder s'est si souvent
promené son esprit vagabonde
meacci riche tapis 3 millions mais n'y
arrivent plus jadot comines tf1 a
racheté net une bibliothèque
ni mende soulignant
des shifts est active à chaud
inventing futaba d'afrique
de l'est
quatre victimes
sont une flûte une armée vinh des frais
appliqués friberg est
elle aussi communie avec la nature
anne-marie baer nous accueille à oldham
hausse un jardin de découvertes sur les
hauteurs de chopper now 7 rbds orist
chevronnés connaît les secrets des
plantes et l'art de confectionner élixir
teinture et autres remèdes
avec l'aide de 14 passionnés anne-marie
dispense son savoir lors de visites
guidées et d'ateliers
quelques 250 plantes aromatiques et
médicinales prospère dans son jardin à
l'abri du vent
parmi toutes les herbes qu'elle marie
cultive une en particulier a sa
préférence
le titre only c'est un monde à part ça
il croque
transmissible par
mark andrews
mais il est temps pour nous de quitter
ce petit coin de paradis
un dernier coup d'oeil sur le canis flou
l un des sommets les plus spectaculaires
de la région de chopard now et nous
reprenons notre route
une vingtaine de kilomètres plus loin en
direction du sud et nous arrivons à
l'alpage de fussent-elles perdu dans les
nuages
cette ferme fromagère est exploitée
depuis plus de trente ans par la famille
meusburger il passe tout l'été sur
l'alpage cette année le travail ne
manque pas leur petite fille est venue
leur prêter main forte
pour fabriquer son fromage et en garde
mme rice bourgueil n'utilise en aucun
cas du lait d'ensilage c'est l'herbe
fraîche de l'alpage qui donnera aux
fromages tout son caractère et son arôme
si particulier les meules sont sales et
brossé tous les jours
ensuite il faut laisser faire le temps
plus un fromage sera affiné plus son
goût sera corsé et savoureux
et en garde produit une meule de fromage
par jour
cette meule peut peser jusqu'à 39 kg
après avoir soutiré le cahier du
chaudron le petit lait y porter à
ébullition jusqu'à ce que de petits
flocons apparaissent à la surface
on obtient alors un breuvage extrêmement
nourrissant et revigorant au goût
étonnamment neutre la zenn soupe
enfin une autre spécialité du breakdance
hochwald celle oxydes un chocolat sans
une once de cacao il est fabriqué à
partir de petits les caraméliser après
une très longue ébullition une friandise
peu ordinaire mais qui ravit les becs
sucrés de l'alpage
un peu plus bas se trouve le hameau de
steinbach l'alpage intermédiaire est un
endroit où les randonneurs aime se
reposer
l'auberge et gander est un poids de
ralliement gourmand très appréciée elle
et qu est-ce qu 9la les pâtes fraîches
au fromage du chef bruno rate on fait la
réputation du lieu c'est un peu le plat
national du vorarlberg
le chef nous explique la recette
de bonnes qu'est ce qu'une leçon de
petite taille un peu humide et surtout
croquantes
tout un art que bruno maîtrise à la
perfection
c'est dommage
bruno ajoute aux pattes un mélange bien
particulier de fromage à différents
stades d'affinage et bien entendu seul
le fromage du bregenz hochwald trouve
grâce à ses yeux s'il y a de l'alpage de
füsun talent ou de shon barre c'est
encore mieux mais il ne nous en dira pas
plus à ce sujet
le mieux c'est encore de venir déguster
les caisses cnof le surplace dans
l'atmosphère chaleureuse et sympathique
et de l'auberge et gander
nous nous rendons à présent à schwarz
enberg à 25 km de là chaque été quatuor
à cordes et récitals de piano viennent
se mêler aux cloches des vaches ce petit
village pittoresque accueille en effet
le plus grand festival du monde dédié à
schubert la schubertiade au beau milieu
des habitations à bardos classé monument
historique
le musée ingres et licata hoffman mérite
qu'on s'y attarde
issu d'une famille modeste de la région
la peintre angelica hoffman a fait une
carrière éblouissante de portraitiste et
de peintre d'histoire
quelques-unes de ses oeuvres ornent les
murs de l'église paroissiale de chartes
lindberg
schwarzenberg est décidément une ville
au rayonnement culturel très important
le poète allemand edwart meuric avait
l'habitude de venir séjourner l'été dans
le breakdancer valt le restaurant
traditionnel hier chez nous était l'une
de ces adresses favorites
à quelques pas du chercheur une petite
fromagerie fait partie des étapes
incontournables de la route du fromage à
première vue il s'agit d'une épicerie
tout ce qu'il ya de plus ordinaire c'est
à la cave que la magie opère la
propriétaire maria funkel est considérée
comme la spécialiste du fromage dans le
breakdancer valdes
je n'ai le crac
hélas
pêche
cet intime téléphone ou deux histoire
sophie cox d'harris mythe on revenir f1
goodis tu te crées sur pc et ça ira
ngota then
the first encounter
à quelques kilomètres de chartres nyberg
la petite ville donne-t-elle ce bourg
est le point de départ de nombreux
chemins de randonnée autrement plus
sportif est l'un d'entre eux fait partie
d'une série de sentiers à thème intitulé
les chemins vers l'eau il mène à la
centrale hydroélectrique dans ce bourg
construite en 1908 sous la monarchie
austro-hongroise est toujours en service
aujourd'hui
le sentier est jalonnée de petites
installations hydro thérapeutique
quelques pas de cigognes dans un bassin
de marche et nous voilà frais et dispos
pour continuer la balade prochain et à
l'exploitation d'ingo metzler à aig
depuis 20 ans une goélette des vaches
laitières et des chèvres fabrique du
fromage et divers produits laitiers
mais ce n'est pas tout avec le petit
lait issu de la fabrication du fromage
et produit toute une gamme de boissons
et de soins cosmétiques naturels riches
en protéines et en vitamines b
enfin une go est également le fondateur
de la première école du fromage du
breakdance hohwald
qui m'a wolverine and she wolf
master just can't buy
et motifs rigueur drastique était massée
dans bing com qui mit au monde
spvm se débrouille
en quatre heures les fromagers en herbe
ont pour mission de fabriquer un fromage
à l'ancienne et à la fin du stage chacun
peut emporter son fromage à la maison
son diplôme de fromage et empoche
de la ferme aux fourneaux à aig l'ancien
restaurant traditionnel engel dont les
parties les plus anciennes datent de
plus de 300 ans abrite aujourd'hui
l'école de cuisine fera au cas où fans
fracas hoffman la voici une cuisinière
de talent qui transmet son savoir faire
et ses valeurs avec passion et
engagement
aujourd'hui elle s'attaque un défi de
taille apprendre à ces cinq gaillards
une recette traditionnelle autrichienne
accordéon contre rouleau à pâtisserie
que tu bats contre tablier le
sympathique groupe de musique
folklorique et chaud près
biostar mais
son crédo tout le monde peut cuisiner
tant que le plaisir est de la partie
pour ses recettes elle privilégie des
produits frais de saison et de la région
des ingrédients simples mais savoureux
à l'école de cuisine les élèves
apprennent une cuisine terrienne aux
recettes ancestrales d'après karine cas
hoffman il faut savoir laisser parler
son intuition et sa sensibilité
culinaires des modèles et
les roulés de choucroute doivent cuire à
couvert pendant trois quarts d'heure
environ jusqu'à ce que tout le bouillon
soit évaporée
magnifique la cuisine autrichienne a de
beaux jours devant elle bravo les
garçons
à dix kilomètres de aig nous arrivons à
la ferme d'alpage église brandon cela
fait plusieurs années qu'avec sa famille
imelda guerre vient s'occuper de
l'exploitation durant l'été outre les 35
vaches venues brouter l'herbe tendre des
moteurs la ferme compte également parmi
ses hôtes des ports des chèvres et un
torrent
après une journée de dur labeur imelda m
confectionner un riebel un plat typique
du vorarlberg
elle commence par délayé de la crème
dans de l'eau tiède qu'elle verse
ensuite dans une sauteuse à feu doux
elle ajoute de la semoule de blé ou de
maïs et mélange lentement la préparation
jusqu'à ce qu'elle épaississe
aujourd'hui rudolph bertl avec qui nous
avions débuté cette balade est venu
faire un petit tour à l'alpage juste
alors pour déguster leur idole ici les
randonneurs de passage sont toujours les
bienvenus
le rib elle s'apprécie sucré avec de la
compote de pommes ou salée avec un bon
morceau de fromage d'alpage c'est un
plat revigorant et chaleureux mais pour
imelda et sa famille c'est avant tout un
moment de partage
le breakdance un valdes compte également
une attraction à ne manquer sous aucun
prétexte
level des rebelles un petit rat
historique entretenu avec soin autrefois
il emmenait les voyageurs jusqu'à ling
ao
c'est justement à lingen how que le
sculpteur a nommé de fleurs a choisi de
s'établir il y vit depuis plus de 20 ans
entre temps il a acquis une grande
renommée dans la région le bréguet
gérard principal cours d'eau du
breakdance hohwald lui fournissons
matériaux favoris le calcaire siliceux
une roche à la texture dense et compact
qui peut être poli comme du marbre
le toucher le contact est une des
thématiques à laquelle il aime se
frotter
lapostolle faudrait que marc ulmann
soldats
le long de la ligue du val d'orbey l'art
se fond dans la nature brute nous sommes
sur le sentier de sculptures dont un
homme et flore est en partie
l'initiateur neuf artistes d'horizons
différentes ont eu pour mission de se
choisir un arbre et de le travailler à
leur manière de le modeler selon leur
inspiration sans autres limites que le
matériau lui-même
des sculptures qui retourneront à la
nature quand le temps aura fait son
oeuvre
un peu plus loin nos pas nous mène vers
une véritable merveille de la nature le
long de la rivière ou barsakh s'étant
l'une des tuffes hier les plus
impressionnantes d'europe l'eau coule
sur la roche en petites rigoles formant
un baldaquin et des rideaux de
concrétions l'eau se transforme en ruche
le tue
gaby auster le guide de randonnée et
pédagogue de la nature aime venir se
ressourcer ici
des chevaux est tout content of the big
to sign et son gosse zeitz trois farines
bassiste sight bobigny projeter sur ces
herbes hautes
j'te parle en marche il en explique
andrew et ben hermans
bel et la
méditation par platts
nous traversons landes humides et
marécageuse à la végétation très
caractéristique c'est encore gaby
strauber chef au restaurant chauloux sa
krumbach qui nous en parlent le mieux
je n'ai que les têtes influent
dans
les malades ont
été
menées contre al palmaert
et
le restaurant de gaby est une ancienne
école qu'elle a rachetée et converti en
temple de la gastronomie
c'est l'une des chefs les plus
innovantes et les plus créatives du
bréguet sur valdes est sans doute l'une
des plus perfectionniste elle rhmani en
permanence ses recettes a filmé les
choix des ingrédients marie les goûts
avec une justesse étonnante
petit coup de projecteur sur les
spécialités de la maison rouleau d'ortie
au fromage de chèvre et aux câpres
ravioles farcies au fromage d'alpage et
de feuilles de consoude et enfin la
glace des marais composée de crème aigre
de jus de citron et de sirop d'érable
rouge
les marais de krumbach l'est un souvenir
inoubliable à ceux qui savent les
observer et les respecter longtemps
l'homme a voulu assécher les zones
marécageuses
difficile à exploiter et réputé
insalubres l impact sur la faune et la
flore mais aussi sur le cycle de l'eau
est aujourd'hui considérable à krombach
la valeur de ce paysage culturel a
heureusement été reconnu à temps
notre balade touche à sa fin mais nous
ne pouvons quitter le breakdancer valdes
s'en aller visiter la yukon werkstatt
l'atelier de costumes traditionnels
harry von burg
ici le visiteur découvre toutes les
étapes de fabrication de la youpi le
costume féminin du breakdance hochwald
par excellence
l'atelier de costumes propose des cours
de confection une partie du bâtiment
abrite également un musée
c'est l'un des costumes européens les
plus anciens est aussi l'un des plus
raffinés
chacune des rues fabriqués ici est un
exemplaire unique et seule une vel de
rinne une habitante du bregenz hochwald
a le droit de porter cette tenue
ancestrales
s'il ayoub continue d'être fabriqué est
porté dans la région c'est sans doute un
peu grâce à martin à mettre leur
professeur d'arts textiles passionnés
du yucatan et c'est là ni tradition
spanish movie
contre x au plus haut var au terme de ce
n'est pas différent
micheline milot prix des familles
reprennent
la route du fromage du break dancer
valdes a décidément beaucoup à offrir
alors à vos chaussures et partez vous
aussi à la découverte de cette région de
triche dont l'hospitalité n'est plus à
prouver